[Musique]
c'est ça tu vois ce qui se passe même à
tarime aux pompiers ont la la la la
vous êtes là à voter eh ben ça par
angers les choses j'ai jamais vu autant
d'agitation dans l'île aux enfants mais
partez pas nous reste et puis on est de
fous plus on rit
en france soir françois qu'est ce qu'il
ya au pardon bonjour je ne vous avais
pas vus excusez moi avec tout le monde
qui a aujourd'hui à aix françois excuse
moi de te déranger mais l'heure est
grave
ouh la la quel ton tragique casimir
qu'est ce qui inquiète c'est que ce
n'est plus possible il faut faire
quelque chose
je viens juste d'être bousculé par une
patinette qui m'a fait un verre à la
pâte en quoi la houle ou là où la
patinette m'est rentré dedans j'ai un
verre à vin nouveau nom est tu veux dire
un bleu mais non tout le monde sait très
bien comme j'ai la peau orange que le
bleu et d'orange ça fait du maire pour
casimir des biens à plaindre j'ai trouvé
une solution une solution
why alors fait bien attention casimir ça
ne réussit pas toujours d'avoir des
idées non mais là je suis sûr de ne pas
me tromper je vais poser des panneaux de
signalisation a très bien née es-tu sûr
de connaître tous les panneaux du code
de la route
ah ouais enfin de toute façon je vais
très bien me débrouiller tout seul je
viens de coire beau faut que je m'en
aille
à tout à l'heure casimir oui françois
n'oublie pas de respecter les panneaux
au moins quand tu reviendras moi aussi
ouais toi aussi
bon ma malle magique où est ma malle
magique à nous l'apporté un bon les amis
vous voulez m'aider à à sortir et à
reconnaître tous les panneaux de
signalisation
ouais bon on va se mettre là voilà bien
voilà on évitera les embouteillages et
les accidents comme ça alors ça qu'est
ce que c'est ah bon sens interdit qu'un
bruno tu le prends celui là vous
connaissez croisement oui mais c'est un
croisement de deux routes semblables
ouais voilà tiens voilà à un autre la
caisse que celle ci encore un croisement
ouais il ya une grande là une route
prioritaire d'une voûte fois où une
grande route et une petite tient laurent
tu le pose un autre assis l'un stop stop
on s'arrête
michel tient ensuite on mettra celui là
aussi il y en aura besoin
oui des changes de tourner à gauche
tiens ben ali un autre fois il y
ressemble au 1er mai la flèche et et
dans l'autre sens un oui tiens le prend
vous voulez poser ainsi vous
embarrassent à un autre intéressant la
recette il est marrant
oui défense de doubler c'est tout voilà
une pique à à ça je crois c'est pas tout
à fait ouais c'est pas une interdiction
que ça veut dire que ouais on peut
s'arrêter on peut se garer un parking
bien pas encore un oui c'est facile
c'est écrit ouais ces deux roues taux
semblable au city voilà on a encore un
dernier la place et mon panneau
personnel bah oui sinon je me ferais
écrasé voyons tam tam tam tam tam tam
macadam tomtom bon et voilà allez les
enfants je vous donnais des ballots
françois interdite par la bombe
on passe par là donc ça fait rien
interdit aussi là pour aller dans les
rayer le kiosque venez venez venez
annonce françois qu'est-ce que tu
parlais à gauche regarde on ne peut pas
les interdits ah oui effectivement bons
ballons passent par la mildt a fait rien
interdit à droite mathieu
non vraiment qu'il admire si c'était
nécessaire de mettre autant mme awa et
alors enfin avec tous ces panneaux on
pourra jamais vivre tranquillement
oh non je trouve ça très pratique est
bien pratique
essayons françois oui oui qu'est ce
qu'il a dit mais bien m'aider je ne peux
plus sortir
regarde je suis entouré de sens interdit
kazemi